[Music]
it was always just my mom and me
to have a family that's what i really
want
no way i got a cousin that is the
whitest man i've ever seen he wants to
meet up
oliver cousin evie it sounds so
jane austen when you say it like that
you know my mom always wanted to take me
to england to learn about our family
history there's a wedding coming up
actually you should come i would love to
but come on everyone is dying to meet
you
[Music]
wow it's incredible
i believe this is one of our important
guests evie this is a close friend of
the family walter deville uh hi hi
looking forward to getting to know you
better
[Music]
what are you doing down there
miss you should return to your room
we're all so delighted that you're here
which one's the ground the groom and his
bride will make their grand entrance
tomorrow
ready
i i can't shake the feeling that
everyone is staring at me
you and walter seem to be getting
awfully close evie
i'm curious though what have you told
you
about us ow
let me see
there she is where are the bride and
groom
as you all know there has been someone
missing from this table
but that once broken bond will be
renewed tonight
to even
my new bride
i want to go home but this is your home
help me please
yeah dear hello mr hawker here there's a
young lady who seems quite distressed
i'm so glad you've come to your senses
my love
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that i can't
i saw a sign in the sky
i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
uh
there's something out there i'm talking
about
you can't i'm trying to protect you
protect me from what
[Music]
it's time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
it knows how to hunt
i know how to survive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
whatever did this
i can kill it
[Applause]
what is he doing here
we found your daughter she's alive
be prepared for changes we have a child
therapist that she'll be working with
four years is a long time what she needs
right now is her family mr
sweetheart
it's mommy
welcome home esther we left it just as
it was
it's lovely to be back i miss my family
very much
our goal here is helping esther
acclimate back into life within the
family unit
[Music]
sorry
i think something's going on with esther
is there anything you want to tell me
about your time way
how is that possible four years ago she
was still drawing stick figures
esther's behavior has been so erratic
hello mommy
thank you mommy
what are you getting at
to me it felt like a performance
if you're not esther who are you
[Music]
the story
the mother protects her family
no matter what
that's the story of
that's the glory of love
[Music]
[Music]
a horrible thing happened to you
i just want you to be able to move on
with your life
come here it's coming up on a year
i have something that's planned and i
need a partner in crime the b67 tv tower
i haven't climbed since becky if you
don't confront your fears you are always
going to be afraid
let's do it
let's climb your stupid tower
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys
[Music]
you're awesome that is the becky that we
need for this trip
this is sick
damn it hunter what are you getting us
into
okay so just stay behind me one wrong at
a
[Music]
it's
time
you're doing great
becky you gotta come up here
[Music]
hey trust me
what was that
hunter how do we get down
i don't have a signal
our water is down there in that bag we
have 50 feet of rope
i think i can drop myself lower
every hour that passes the weaker we get
if anyone called
what is it that dan 911 to say if you're
scared of dying don't be afraid to let
what is it you like to talk about
i'm patient
hi
i know you're nervous i just want to
have a chat
i'm seeing something no one else can see
except for me
it's smiling at me
yesterday a patient in your care died
brutally in front of you
[Music]
i need to find an explanation for what
happened
it's smiling at me
at me
[Music]
[Music]
i found 20 cases involving 19 victims of
the direct line linking them all
together
[Applause]
you said only 19
[Music]
why is it that everybody else who's seen
it is dead in your life
i've seen it too
[Music]
how long between each victim's stuff
none of them survived longer than a week
today is my fourth day i am not gonna
keep running
i have to face it
how does it make you feel
[Music]
i'm just really scared that something
bad is going to happen
[Applause]
these sessions are mandatory for all
staff sister anne
my mother struggled with depression
annie annie honey can i come in
but even as a child i knew it was danny
open the door please
more
[Music]
my mother talked about hearing that
voice
inside she said the voice didn't really
want her
it wanted me
the citadel has fallen black smoke
blocks out the sun because as some of
you may already know we have a female
student in the class only as an observer
so
let's descend into the mouth of hell
shall we
there are more possessions reported
today than at any other time in history
so we must fight for every soul
[Music]
defend us in battle against the spirits
of wickedness
[Music]
i believe the demon that is tormenting
natalie and the demon that possessed my
mother are one in the same
i'd like to teach sister just enough to
protect herself and others
this relationship she has
it's personal
we've been waiting for you
[Music]
your mother has a pretty voice
be careful
once you know the devil
the devil's knows you
[Music]
oh you've got to be kidding me
yeah this is 476 barbary right yeah i'm
renting this place no i booked it a
month ago are you sure you have the
right place yeah who am i supposed to do
why don't you come inside and we'll call
these idiots
[Music]
why don't you just crash here oh no
i don't know if you've got a great look
at this neighborhood
but i don't think you should be out
there by yourself
it's dry and there's a lock on the door
by the way i'm keith tess
you take the bedroom and i'll sleep out
here on the couch
oh god
[Music]
keith
keith
this process might seem overwhelming
but with a little practice
it can soon become
a pleasurable experience
this is perfectly natural
good evening
welcome to hawthorne it'll be our
pleasure to feed you tonight will be
magical
over the next few hours you will ingest
fat
salt
protein
and at times entire ecosystems we're
eating the ocean we're eating the ocean
are you crying
it's just i find it all very moving so
it's okay but i'm not as into this as
you are
oh my god
you shouldn't be here tonight
[Music]
you my dear guests
are not the common man isn't that right
is he gonna keep doing that what happens
inside this room is meaningless compared
to what happens outside
we're about a frightened nanosecond
nature is timeless
what the hell is going on
i love you all
any questions
this is bergamot i'm getting chef
yes it is
[Music]
you don't have to be nervous i'm not
nervous
well
so impressive you're impressive they're
gonna be obsessed with you i just want
to feel good they're not as nihilistic
as they look on the internet you guys
this is me oh
whoa
this is your first relationship oh no
you just kind of give that vibe
oh you know that has weed in there right
[Applause]
[Music]
who wants to play body spotty spotties
so how do you play
if you draw the piece of paper that has
the x on it you are the murderer let's
go
and if you're the murderer you have to
kill someone by touching them on the
back
the most important part if you come
across a body you have to yell
[Music]
is that the lights
david
our friend is dead
someone's doing this we're trying to
kill us off one by one that'll be so
obvious if i were the
killer for the neighbor
where are you
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm staying safe really because it looks
like you're grabbing a meat cleaver to
go look for my boyfriend
[Music]
is
[Music]
i brought something what is it
it's zucchini bread
yum
girl pop girl rich girl i'm a girl false
girl catch me if you can go
hey check this out
[Music]
three days of paddling three days don't
worry i'll take it easy on you
i thought i heard something
that thing is stalking us
we have to help her the next island has
reception on people okay what about
boats
we head for that island it'll come for
us again
it's not gonna stop
[Music]
what if i told you
that today
you'll leave here
i'm talking
to you
bro what'd you see someone above the
clouds that's big i'll be
you think whatever kill pops is out
there
[Music]
right here
you
are gonna witness
an absolute spectacle
[Music]
what happens next
are you ready
are you ready
[Music]
here we go
recipient opportunity i'm talking rich
and famous for life there's plenty of
videos for flying [ __ ] online you know
nobody gonna get what we gonna get we
gonna get the money shot what's up
undeniable proof of aliens on camera
the oprah shot
you guys gonna tell me what's going on
hell no
something out here are you the only
person in the world that can get it on
film
that cloud they moved an edge it's
aliens
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up our asses
i'll be rooting for you
i think we pissed them off yeah they
repainted your house
they gonna come back
you ready
we got some work to do
nope i'll get him out
and i'll get the shot let's go baby
let's go
[Music]
i need y'all to tell me what did you see
in a cloud
[Music]
well it's not what you think
they took me
they took them all i gotta get out this
house i'm trying to save you my brother
is out there
i don't think they thank you
if you don't look at it
let's dream you're chasing
where you end up at the top of the
mountain
it's the one you never wake up from
you'll be getting a call from my
supervisor asking how my service was
five stars angel five stars
[Music]
uh
happy dancers
[Music]
so
[Music]
happy dancers
[Music]
[Music]
ah
happy dancers
[Music]
[Music]
i a long way from home
[Music]
this is where you tell me you're going
to help me get my sister back
i've seen the bodies
they're terrorists the killers ain't
that
we need you
who's your sister
oh
fantastic
you reckon you can get us in there
easy
i'm gonna make this right
so i'm gonna go into that bunker
and we're gonna kill every last one of
those sons and [ __ ] how can i
oh what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
oh yes
that's one hell of a lovely skull good
work rhys you dumb son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
come on
what the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] me
[Music]
i can feel you pulling things around in
there
it's a brand new organ
never before seen
[Music]
we've all felt that the body was empty
empty of meaning
[Music]
and we've wanted to confirm that
so that we could feel it with meaning
[Music]
the world is a much more dangerous place
now that pain has all but
[Music]
disappeared surgery is sex isn't it
is it
you know what it is
surgery is the new sex
[Music]
i don't like what's happening with the
body
in particular what's happening with my
body
[Music]
which is why i keep cutting it up
what do you think they'd find inside
outer
[Music]
oh
space
sorry
let us not be afraid to map the chaos
inside
[Music]
let us create a map
that will guide us
into the heart of darkness
[Music]
the women in our parents generation
they were more into femininity you know
what i mean
because i think you would just look
great in a dress but i mean if you were
pretty much done actually thank you if
it's cool i'm just going to snag these
leftovers
i don't even know how you do it really
do it dating people
no no
you do not need a man okay
so don't play the games just be you
straight out the gate
do you live around here
because i live on aisle six
that was terrible
it was kind of terrible
what's his instagram i want to stalk a
little bit you just have one say what
yeah oh no see that's
that's shady let's play a game tell me
something you don't want me to know i
hate this okay don't put all our hopes
of finding happiness through someone
else
yeah girl you all digmatized and i
haven't even seen this dude
what's going on i'm gonna tell you but
you're gonna freak out
no this isn't happening
yeah it's happening
no games than what you wanted
it's about giving
giving yourself over to somebody
[Music]
becoming one forever
that's love
it's a straight girl's fantasy come true
right
would you like to see a magic trick yeah
[Music]
tell me your name
taylor
i was really starting to like you
finney
i almost let you go
[Music]
don't hang up who are you
you know all our names
it doesn't work
hang it up
i made you some breakfast would you put
that
salt and
[Music]
pepper have you seen this boy
my brother he was taken
with black balloons
i had a dream about it
please let the dreams be real
you're getting out of here oh
there's a combination what's the
combination
[Music]
[Music]
the creepiest damn thing
we're still trying to figure out what
happened
[Music]
when did you last hear from her
she left to bring her to school
is everything okay
has she gone missing before
not in a long time
mom
i heard about your mom
is she all right
hey
it doesn't feel right
i think we should go away just the two
of us think you should take it easy at
the
moment
mom
where did you go
i can't tell you
oh yeah
are you awake
what's wrong with you
there's things i need to tell you
it's not your mother up there
if we don't do something we'll never get
her back
and then they'll try to take you
dance with me sure
mom stop
where's your mom
[Applause]
this isn't funny amber would you like to
[Laughter]
all doors locked
doors unlocked
hello
it's happening
three attacks so far do you have a gun
i'm sydney prescott of course i have a
gun
something about this one just feels
different
samantha
i'm i know who you are i've been through
this
a lot
this is your life now which means that
whoever this is is going to keep coming
for you
[Music]
you ready
for this
never oh
there are certain rules to surviving
the attacks were all on people related
to the original killers
whatever his link is to our past
it's pulled us all back here
and i won't sleep until he's in the
ground
hello sydney
it's an honor
[Music]
hello hi this is marlo yes
harper yes
come in
the words i have to say it's a beautiful
house
will it just be you staying
excuse me mrs muller no
until you give your love
there's nothing more that we can do
happen from the garden yeah it was
delicious no no
mustn't do that
forbidden fruit oh god sorry i i'm
drinking
oh
you're tormented
it feels more like
haunted
yeah something happened
my husband
went upstairs to our balcony
and let himself go
you must wonder why you drove him to it
why i didn't drive him into it
i could be true
but if you'd given him the chance to
apologize
he'd still be alive
what
a man
followed me out of the woods
he was stalking me what makes you say
that i saw him twice
twice
i don't know if he saw you once
[Music]
i'll play a game
you hide
i'll see
you must feel an awful sense of
guilt
stay away from me
[Music]
something feels weird
something's changing you remember the
tools you type right
pencil desk paper shoes you're weird
everything okay charlie
it happened again what happened to that
thing if you ever start to lose control
what do you do it didn't work she's not
a robot and she's a little girl
with little girls emotions which are
wildly unpredictable
charlie she just has to shove it down
and keep it hidden
our responsibility is getting her ready
our responsibility
is to protect her charlie
if they catch her they're gonna put her
in a cage charlie
they're gonna run tests on her for the
rest of her life
i'll never see her again
if who catches me
something's happened i need it handled
with discretion
and i need her back alive holy [ __ ]
do you know what it means to be on the
run bad men are after us really bad i
hate living like this
you're special charlie i'm not special
i'm a monster
i want to help her you want to use her
charlie don't be stupid
do you feel that
let her go it's gonna get a lot worse
it's the first of her kind
a real
life superhero
you need to understand how to use it
it can't be a reaction it's got to be a
decision
that's the only way that you control it
she's becoming a young woman i'm not
going to jail and someday soon
you gotta change the world
she may be capable of a nuclear
explosion
on your knees simply with the force
trust me charlie you don't have to be
afraid
please i can help you liar liar
pants on fire
i don't want to hurt anyone
but it feels kind of good
[Music]
you